>> Brian: I'M SURE YOU NOTICED
OUR SOUTHER BORDER HAS BEEN A
MESSLL YEAR.
NEARLY 2.2 MLION ILLEGALS.THAT T
ALONE THE GOT-AWAYS ARE CROSSING
ALREADY THI YEAR.
IT'S NOT OVER.BUT, VICE PREDENTA
HARRIS IS OE AGAIN NOWHERE TO
BE FOUND.
THIS IS HER J.
EVEN DEMOCRATS ARE UPS ABOUT
ITCASE IN POINT.
CONGRESSMANENRY CUELLAR QUOTED
TODAY SAYING HE RECENTLY
REALED HE CALLED THE V.P. THIS
MMER TO OFFER AICE ON BORDER
ISSUES.
IS FROM A BORDER STATE.
AND A BORDER CY.
T HE NEVER HEARD BACK.THEY SAME.
SEEMS UNINTERESTED HE KIN OF
GAVE UP ON HER IOVED PAST HER.
APPARENTLY GRIPINGO THE "NEW
YORK TIMES" SHE HASN'T SPPED
YET ABOUT HER BS.HER MEDIA COVEE
IN THE WHITE HOUSELL IN
TODAY' PAPER.
THE ARTICLE RDS LIKE THIS.
WHILE MOSTRESIDENTS PROMISEPRESD
EQUALL
MR. BIDEN DOES NOTEEL A NEED
FROM INPUT FROM MS. HARRIS AS HE
NAVARRO GATES SOME OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT RELATNSHIPS.
SO KAMALA HARRIS FEELS LIKE S
IS BEING LEFT OUT AND SHE IS
SPEAKING OUT
BUT IT WAST ALWAYS LIK THI
AT THE BEGINNG OF THE
ADMINISTRATI, SHEAS SIDE BY
SIDE WH THE PRESIDENT FOR
EVERY PUBLIC APPRANCE.
'LL CAN'T FORGET SHE WAS T
LAST ONE IN THE ROOM WHEN THE
PRESIDT DECIDED TO PULLUT OF
AFGHISTAN.
AND THAT WENT RLLY WELL.
IT LOOKED LIKE THINGS STARTED
OUT GREAT.
WHAT WENT WRONG ANDHY IS
KAMALA HARS SUGGLING SO
BADLY AND TALKING ABOUT IT WE'RE
GOING TO ASK TWO PEOPLE THA
KN QUITE WELL.
IN FAC T "NEW YORK TIMES"
WOULD BE DIFFERENT IF SHE WERE
L OF HER 4 PDECESSORS ALL
WHITE, ALL MAL
JOINING U NOW TO REACT FOX NEW
CONTRIBUTOR PSIDENT BUSH'S
IEF OF STAFF KL ROVE AND
FOER WHITE HSE PRESS
SECRETARY CO-HOST OF OUTMBERED
AND THIS BRAND NEW BOOK THAT'S A
BEST SELLERFOR SH A TIME AS
THIS."
KAYLEIGH McENANY.CAILEE, LET'S U
RE YOU STUNNED TO S THIS?
CLEARLY TH IS A STRATEGY.
SHE TALKED TO THE "A. TIMES,"
THE SAN ANCISCO CHRONICLE.
CBS TEVISION AND THEN TSSTORY.
>> WELL, FIRST CNN -- I JUST
SAID THAT CNN HIT PIECE AGAINST
KAMALA HRIS YOU KNOW YOU HAVEANT
AINST YOU OR AT LEAST THE
REPORTINGS CNN HAD THREE DOZEN
SOURCES.
CITING THE KALA HARRIS'
OFFICE.
IS ARTICLE IN THE "NEYORK
TIME" AGAIN A LIBERAL
PUBLATION HAD TWO  DOZEN
SOURCES.
WHAT WAS SO T ME IN THIS PIE,
BRIAN  THE OPENING ANTIDOTE
WHERE THEY TALKBOUT JOE
MANCHIN COMG INTO THE WHITE
HOUSE LEFT WINGBOUT T GO INTO
THE OVAL OFFICE ANDAINTERLY
KAMALA HARRIS I THERE WITHOE
BIDEN.RATHER THAN BRIING KAMALAO
THEEETING,E SAYS T HER, Y
KN, GIVE A SMILE I'M
PARAPHRASING HERE, SAY HELLO TO
JOEANCHIN AND THENHE GOES
BACK TO HER OFFICE.
SHE FELT SELINED IN THE
RESULTING HDLINE WAS YOU KNO
WE NEED KAMALA TO WIN NOT
NECESSARIL TO GOVER
BU WHAT IS INTERESTING T M
WHILE KAMALA MAYEE THATANTIDOTEG
SIDELINED AT THE HEA.
'S H INCPETENCE.
BECAUSE SHE WT OUT ON WT
VIRGINIA AIRWAYS AND LASHED OUT
AT WILL AIRWAYS MOVE NO OWOULD .
SIDELINED HER OWN INAT THE TENSE
AT THE HEA.
>> Brian: IF IT WAS DICK CHENEY
SAYING ITR KEY STAFFER SAYIN
IT, THE WHITE HOUSE HAS TO
ADDRESS THIS, CORRECT?
DON'T YOU THINK THERE H BEEN A
PHONE CALL OR VISIT ALREADY?
>>
>> I SUSPECT THERE H BEEN
CONVERTION BETWEEN THE WHI
HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF A THE
CHIE OF STAFF FOR THE VICE
PRESIDENT.
BU THIS IS HIGHLY UNUSUAL.
I DON'T REMEMBER THIS HAPPENI
UNDER PRESIDENTRUMP, UNDER
PRESIDENT OBAMA, CERINLY
DIDN'T HAPPENNDER PRESIDENT
BUSH.
I DON'T REMEMBER IT HAPNING
UNDER BILL CLINT BUSH 41R
RONALD REAGAN.
WERE SEEING SOMETHING PLA OUT
HERE THAT'S HIGHLY UNUSUAL.
IHINK IT GS CAILEE'S POINT.
SHE WLD BE GETTING CRITICIZED
IF SHE WERE COMPETENT ANDAKE
IMMIGRATIO
RATHER TN BE INVOLVED I THE
REAL IMMIGTION PROBLEM THE
OBLEM THAT REPRESENTIVE
ELLAR WASALLING HER ABOUT
MAINLY 2 TRILLION COMING ACROSS
OUR BORDER STRAINING STATE ANDLM
TO THE LIMIT AND BEYD, INSTEAD
WHAT SHE SAYS HER PROBLEM, HER
RESPSIBILITY IS TO DEAL WITH
TH IMMIGRATION, THE THRUST FROM
IMMIGRATION COMING OM THE
TRIANGLE.
>> GUATEMALA, HONDUS AND
NICARAGUA NOT TO COME DLING
WITH WHAT'S HAPPENING ONUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
SH HAS BEEN DINING HERSELF
OUT OF THE RE PROBLEMS.
IFOU ARE NOT DEALI WITH THE
REAL PROBLEMS.
PEOP ARE GOING TO LK AT YOUAND ?
E NEVER ATTACKED HER
PORTFOO.
SAID I DON'T LIKE THE JOB WAS
GIVEN ESSENTIALLY.
REN BASS WENT TO BAT FOR HER
TOO AINST THE PRESIDENT.
GOOD LUCK WITH THA THISTORY
CAMEUT I WANT YOU TO COMMENT
CLEE, AN EXCERPT ABOUT THE
MORALE INHE WHITE HOUSE.
QUOTE, IN THE FST YEAR OF THEBIY
HA BEEN FLEETG.
MANY TEENS SUFFENG FROM LMORALER
OFFICIS.
CREATI THE POTENTIAL FOR
HIGHER THAN USUAL TNOVER AS
FOR THE BINNING O A ATHE
END OF ONE YEAR AND BEGINNING O
THE NEXT.
THE SATISFIESEACHED OUT TO
EM, CAILEE.>> YEAH.
THAT'S RIGHT.LOOK, WE HAD A LOTN
THERUMP WHITE HOUSE.SOMEING REG.
YOU WANT TOE ON BOARD, YOU
NEED A TEA MOVING FORWARD TOR
THEMERICAN PEOPLE.
HATEO SEE THI HAPPENING FOR
BIDEN LE IT DID FOR TMP.
INDICATESOMETHING BIG GOING ON
HERE.
THEY ARE TALKING POLITICO
PLAYBOOK A LOT OF THESE
STAFFERS, THEYEEL LEFTUT ANDMARF
MEETING I WAS IN THE WTE HOUSE
DURING MARK MEAWS EVERY SINGLE
MONDAY HAD A MEETING WHERE WE
ALLENT IN.
TOTHER AND WE TALKEDHROUGH
THE ISSUES.
ANDHAT WAS DURG THE HEIT
OF THE PANDEMI
I GET THERE ARE UNIQUE
RCUMSTANCES BUT YOU GOT HAVE
MEETINGS LIKE THAT.
EVEN IF TY'RE ON THEHONE.
THE IS A YEAR WHERE WE HAD
COD ON THE DOWNTURN A L OF
THE LEAKING.
>>RETTY INTERESTING KARL,
THIS IS WHAT THEY SD, SOME
STAFFERS SAY IS THE RESULT O
AN INSULAR TOP-HEAVY WHITE HSE
LONG-TIME BIDEN AIDE MUCH O
THE STAFF.
NO NEW FRIENDS IN BIDEN WORLD.
FINAL THOUG?
>> YEAH, THE SATE AIDS
SURROUND FORMER SATOR JOE
DEN THAT IS A PROBLEM.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS MORE
EFFECTIVE WHEN ITAS CLEAR
COMMUNICATIONSP AND DOWN AND
TH THERE IS A INS NATURE
TOHIS WHITEOUSE.IT EFFECTS N ONE
WHIT HOUSE,T ALSO EFFECTS T
QUALITIES OF THE PRESINT'S
DIRECTION AND ITS LDERSHIP.
BECAUSTHEY A NOT LISTENING,
THEY ARE NOT REACHIN OUT.
AN THEY ARE WTING F THEIR
GUIDANCE FRO HIM RATHER THAN
HELPING HIM SPE THE RHT
DECISION
>> Ban: BIGGESTURPRISE FOR
ME.
I TUGHT THEY GET THIS STU
SET A MAYBE THEOLICIES WE
WOULD BE DEBATG THEY CAN'T GET
THEIR PLAYBOO AND THEY C'T
GET EVERYONE TO LINE UP THE
RIGHT WAY.
HEY, KAYLEIGH McENANY,ARL
ROVE, YOUR MISSION NOW IS TO
HAVE AREAT CISTMAS.THANKS SO MU.